démocratie le mur les vies noires comptent
coronavirus
écriture division des débats pro-vie
[Musique]
je viens d'avoir 18 ans l'année dernière et je
vote pour Biden
[Musique] la
démocratie est en jeu dans cette élection
Biden n'est pas parfait et je ne suis pas d'accord
avec
tout ce qu'il défend mais il
sera
tellement meilleur que ce qu'est Trump
[Musique]
en ce moment, l'économie est l'un de nos problèmes les plus
importants et
euh Donald Trump est clairement meilleur pour
gérer l'économie
que Biden et Obama à l'
époque  qu'ils étaient au bureau,
Donald Trump a fait un excellent travail avec
ça avec le coronavirus en termes de
préparation
et de distribution des fournitures euh vous savez, il a en quelque sorte
hérité d'une situation où il n'avait pas de
fournitures, donc
il a dû partir de zéro  à 100 très
rapidement et évidemment le vaccin
avance dans le sens de la
rhétorique de Trump met ma vie en danger
en tant que sino-américain,
il met en danger la vie de mes amis
noirs hispaniques,
tout le monde et surtout mes amis lgbtq et plus,
je vote pour chacun d'entre eux qui
ne peut pas voter
je les soutiens et je ne suis pas d'accord avec
la rhétorique, la violence et la
haine que Trump répand. J'ai
toujours soutenu les
démocrates et j'aime beaucoup plus Biden
que Trump mais je vais probablement
écrire dans quelqu'un d'autre DC  selon toute
vraisemblance, je soutiendrai massivement
Joe Biden, donc j'ai l'impression que je ne
dois pas nécessairement
le soutenir pour qu'ils gagnent, les
deux candidats ont des avantages et des inconvénients,
je suis très catholique donc beaucoup de
choses pro-vie sont  en ce qui
me concerne, c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur lequel je
base une grande partie de mon vote, donc
[Musique]
la première chose dont je me souviens, c'est de construire le
mur et j'ai pensé que c'était une
blague complète, je vais voter pour Biden, je
vote aussi  pour
Joe Biden et Kamala Harris, je pense que l'
Amérique est
un creuset et c'est un groupe de gens qui
se réunissent pour s'améliorer
pour leurs familles et pour leur
objectif commun de simplement faire
mieux pour leur pays et vous le voyez
davantage avec
Biden et  ce dont il parle, c'est d'une
communauté
alors que Trump, c'est juste beaucoup de division
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
je suis chrétien et il y a certaines
choses vers lesquelles les démocrates s'orientent et ces
derniers temps,
je suis un peu mal à l'aise avec lesquelles j'ai l'impression
Biden
va travailler pour tous les Américains
personnellement, vous savez, quand il s'agit de
LGBT,
vous savez que je fais partie de cette communauté et j'ai
peur de
ne pas avoir le droit d'épouser quelqu'un
un jour parce qu'il
pourrait me l'enlever ou le
l'administration, vous savez, pourrait le voter,
vous savez, revenir à la
régression traditionnelle, à ce que
ce soit faux, donc de toute façon, nous sommes francs
et Sarah
et nous sommes enregistrés en tant que républicains. L'expérience du
président Trump en tant
qu'homme d'affaires
et impliqué dans le commerce international, son
expérience
est très précieuse, alors nous avons  ces
autres problèmes
comme l'immigration où il y a un
réseau de criminels qui traversent la
frontière et d'ailleurs
et c'est pourquoi nous avons besoin du mur pour
le bien commun
[Musique]
j'étais un peu en conflit, j'avais l'habitude de
soutenir Trump,
je vote honnêtement pour Biden  J'étais très
en conflit au début, je
voulais en quelque sorte éviter de regarder les médias,
alors j'ai regardé les débats et
j'ai essayé de
formuler mes propres opinions et
honnêtement, en me basant sur ses politiques et
ce qu'il avait dit et quoi.  J'ai vu dans
les débats que j'ai en quelque sorte décidé de
voter pour lui,
je pense que c'est un très bon futur Donald
Trump sélectionné, je pense que ce sera
un hiver sombre si Joe Biden est élu
[Musique]
mais nous devrons le faire.  Je vais devoir attendre et
voir en 2016,
nous pensions que nous savions ce qui allait se passer et
puis c'était quelque chose de différent donc l'
avenir
est aussi brillant que vous le souhaitez
[Musique]
j'aime Kamala Harris, elle est
une patronne,
vous